hi I'm silver at and we're playing
roller coaster second three today you
know what the do is with this my
neighbors are currently doing some
shenanigans in their garden and it
sounds like they're trying to land an
airplane over there but hopefully that's
not going to be too much of an issue in
any case I've got Oliver heldens
blasting through my ears which are calm
and because YouTube copyright problems
that surrounds for another time actually
that's around for no other time for that
I should talk about roller coaster
kethry what am I even doing this
building over here is going to be
somewhat of a it's really hard to
explain but I guess I can actually kind
of get at what I want to do at that spot
even though I suddenly start building
another building because I was like yeah
I'll do that other thing later on
because at the end of the Main Street I
was thinking about whatever I could do
over there and I feel like the best
thing to do is to have some symmetrical
but then again not entirely symmetrical
type of building so you leave the main
street and they get one big square
that's essentially the idea of the pike
layout so far but you leave the main
street and I have the square with
something in the middle of it I'm not
entirely sure what I want to have there
have been some people who say that I
need a fountain somewhere but yesterday
in a stream somebody said what are those
things called again
chair swings and yeah honestly a chair
swing would look pretty cool in there as
well but the carousel is also the kind
of standard thing and yeah that's
basically the kind of problem that I
have right now though it's not really a
problem it's just that I need to think
about whatever I want to have in the
middle of the park right there but I
just want to have some very similar
facades at least in terms of style
around that so you get that very Paris
ish thing where many of the buildings at
some places especially around those
monuments actually aren't the same but
they have the same style of heights and
shape and things like that which i think
is because of I think there's a height
limit in the centre of Paris which is
actually pretty cool you should have
that in cities that's one thing to note
about main streets main streets are the
best when all the buildings are around
the same height not exactly but at least
they have the same amount of floors and
no real building sticks out unless it's
a tower and that is a general kind of
rule which you can apply to Main Street
it mainly exists in cities because they
have the aforementioned
height limits very often in the centre
of the city so it doesn't get
ruin my big skyscrapers and stuff like
that but you always have the city halls
and the churches that everyone everyone
wants to be bigger and that is also
something that you can always keep in
mind while building Main streets this
building over here is just a bit of a
simple counterpart of the other building
on the other side also this is the first
building of the new side which this is
bit of a funny story well basically my
streams right now are way too much ahead
of my let's plays I think it's about
three episodes or something and as I am
speaking the Main Street is actually
almost finished and you'll see that very
soon I'll try uploading a video every
day and if not every two days so we'll
catch up pretty soon but basically
there's a bit of a dilemma of which side
of the Main Street is the better side in
terms of buildings and stuff and the
left side is actually winning I mean the
right side is winning so the old side is
winning so that means that the new parts
aren't going to be quite as great in
most people's opinion so far but I guess
you'll see at some point actually no I
think it was it was the other way around
the left side won oh my god I can't even
remember anymore it was a straw poll but
I don't have the time to go there and
then the case in whatever that's a cool
thing to say at that points to just ask
people what the better side even though
it doesn't really matter too much it's
just something that I'm kind of
interested in because they will be
slightly different there will be some
slight differences in the styles of both
sides in the left side coming from the
entrance that is it's going to have a
couple more Main Street ish buildings in
the sense that they are less general
European like the Alpine building is for
example that's next to this building
that I'm building right now and this is
going to be one of those two symmetrical
buildings and they're going to be
symmetrical in the sense that they both
have the same structure with two white
wings on both sides and a diagonal Tower
in the middle but I do want them to be
slightly different in terms of custom
scenery use and colours as well so it
gets a symmetrical picture across but
it's not exactly the same I think that's
the best idea to dive into this and this
building overall just a bit a bit of a
rip off with the other buildings that I
already have this is this thing with
that first building which was disk
completely an experiment with the style
and mostly the kalos because that first
bill
started with those light brown mixed
with very light blue and that very dark
red for the roof in which the light blue
would be the walls and the light brown
would be the accents and the roof had an
entirely different color but it actually
worked a lot better than I expected and
I guess I can chalk the the fact that I
didn't expect too much out of the
building at first but now it's one of my
favorites of the main street is due to
due to the fact that one of the main
rules that people want to buy - when
building Main streets but one building
buildings in general is but yeah this
especially comes from Main streets
because you have many colors but I need
to get to that already okay the the bit
the rule basically is that you should
keep your color use to either the
accents of the building or the walls and
my accents we mean anything from
balconies to corner stones to windows
and random decorations so if you have
white walls you see for example brown
accents or red accents but if you have a
building with a red wall most likely
that's going to be a brick texture kind
of thing then you'd probably have white
corner stones and white windows and this
is something you do see very often so
it's a bit of a rule that people always
try to follow and I guess it's a very
good idea because it's a handy way to
not have to come up with ingenious color
schemes but also not have the danger of
building a building and then realizing
that the color scheme just doesn't work
out because the colors don't work out
together if you keep all the accents to
one thing and then all the walls to one
thing and if either one of those is
white or I guess if you have a very dark
theme it could also be black because
black goes with anything but then again
black is a color you'd kind of want to
avoid in a theme park you do want to
keep it kind of happy and uplifting
unless you're in the spooky part at
least but that's mainly that one basic
rule and I was yeah I wouldn't call it
confused but I was pretty surprised and
actually happy to see that the buildings
which didn't follow that rule at all and
just were a [ __ ] of colors works
out a lot better than I expected this is
not to say that that rule is stupid it
is definitely something which you should
follow in most cases but it's just it
goes to show you that some color schemes
can work out a lot but
then you expect beforehand so you can
never really write off a color scheme as
terrible before you can actually see
what it actually looks like I guess now
this by the way is just some backstage
thing and this is something that I
probably should talk about because I
haven't really done this before to much
the only thing well I did do it is in
Verona Valley and I think in Verona
Valley I did this backstage and by that
I mean these things are back stages of
course but I mean that I didn't do them
in the time lapses themselves because
what I want to do in this park and what
I haven't really done in either rose
gardens or the other Park is to not only
get a realistic layout done in terms of
the theme park itself and where the
guests can go but also slightly focus on
the background areas and by slightly
focusing I mean that I'll be focusing on
getting them to look nice and realistic
but not putting too much time in it
because it really seems like a wasted
effort to start working on backstage
areas for many many hours but then again
I would like them to be realistic to
actually look at the park from an aerial
perspective and see how it works and
things like that because it just seems
like something that I've missed out on
before and I really want this park to be
as realistic as I can this is going to
be not hyper realistic because it's
still a bit of it's still on Molokai so
you can three and it's still a bit of a
fantasy park but then again I do want it
to seem like it actually functions also
unlike my other Pike's I also want this
to be somewhat functioning when it comes
to the peeps so I do want the peeps to
be able to enter the rides and I am
planning on actually getting some
coasted gates for once because when it
comes to realism on the very small
coaster details like lockers and fast
fast lanes and stuff like that I've
never really been up to date because
I've never been much of a theme park
person to be very honest I'm I'm kind of
in this community because I like the
game a lot and I just like being
creative in general but I'm sorry I'm
just pretty dumb when it comes to theme
park stuff and most of what I do know
I've been taught by other people so yeah
that's just about me for a second so I I
figured then I should actually zoom in
on Fast Pass use and just general theme
park detail
that I normally always miss out on just
for that extra layer of detail or at
least realism in the pike and that's to
some women I went to strive as well for
him know this building this building is
going to be this coding in this building
was going to be a bit of a Dutch
building because I figured no no I could
actually add some Dutch ish influences
in this point but as you may know there
aren't really any Dutch custom scenery
sets before you say so what are you
saying there's CTR sins
Dutch colonial thingamajig which there
is and that's a beautiful set and I'm
actually going to use that in this park
it doesn't look Dutch in the sense that
I go outside or go to a Rotterdam or
Amsterdam and find old buildings over
there it's almost the type of theme park
I would say but it very much conforms to
the efteling I I guess that's just my
idea in general it's um it's a way of
Dutch that I never really see too often
and I went into this building thinking
that that would actually be a good idea
and then I started doing that mock tudor
thing and it turned into more of an
english building but that actually
looked kind of well that looks
surprisingly good I was really expecting
that mock tudor thing to not work
whatsoever because you know we have the
Main Street buildings around this but it
actually worked surprisingly well I'm
also quite surprised because those brick
walls over there are from the wall might
set so the wall Mart is actually looking
good for once and in general um I kind
of like this building even though I
still have no idea what exactly it wants
to be it looks much more English than
the original Dutch then I went into it
for which is which goes to show that if
you want to do a Dutch building just
leave out the to do stuff just leave out
all the wind beams and stuff like that
because that is never going to work
unless you're building like some sort of
special farm or something like that but
yeah I want to get some kind of Dutch
area so I really need to start working
on a customer scenery set and I'll do
that very shortly because it's mostly in
the small details that a building is
Dutch which is other than its size the
types of chimneys that it uses and types
of cornerstones and cornices so that is
something to get into but that kept that
goes for the rest of the themes as well
because they're all quite underused but
yeah that's it for this episode thank
you for watching and I'll see you on the
next